- I think what we're
seeing for the first time
in American history,
since America has become
like a worldwide
cultural institution,
starting like the early
1900s to some extent,
is you're having creative
types fleeing these liberal,
you know, currently democratic
areas like LA, New York,
and everyone's
moving to red states,
to Austin, to Miami
and a few others.
This has never happened
before, where the creativity
goes to the republican party
and I don't see how
you reverse that trend.
(mid tempo electronic music)
- All right, Dave Rubin,
and we're doing something
a little different today.
I am live in studio with my
guest, who is just outside.
I have not seen him yet
but I've been told that
he is wearing a tiny mask
due to proper safety
protocols related to COVID.
Here he is, Michael-- (laughs)
Michael malice.
Welcome to the Rubin Report.
It's good to see you again.
Yes, feel my face. (laughs)
This is very exciting.
I didn't know what you are
going to be doing today.
You told me you had
something in store for me.
It's good to see you.
- I wish I could say the
same, but I can't honestly.
- First off, I love the
suit, the color is great.
The shirts, nice tie
the whole shebang.
Where did you get this
little face get up?
I know you've been--
COVID's very serious and you've
been very serious about it.
- You didn't even
praise the shoes.
- No, your shoes
the whole thing.
- These are seal
leather from the '70s.
- Is that right?
When you could get seal leather.
- That's right.
- Yeah, that's very impressive.
- Not like nowadays.
- No, no, no.
You can't get it, you have to
get on the black market now.
I have a feeling
we're going to do
the entire interview this way.
- Of course, this is
we can't joke around.
- [Dave] No, no,
this is serious.
- I don't want to
kill your grandma.
- No, thank you, they're
both dead, actually already.
So you've been walking
around like this, I assume,
wandering through LA with your?
- I have a little cane
and one of those dogs
and I fit right in.
Now, this is what
I want to ask you.
One of the things that I've
seen when I was walking around
LA, I'm from New
York, as you know,
people know I lived
there all my life.
And now I'm at the point where
I'm joined the chorus of--
Well, let me take a step back.
As a New Yorker, you're
always defending New York
at its worst, right?
When people attack
it for being filthy,
for being crowd or
for people being rude,
all my life, I've said
you just don't get it,
you don't understand,
or that's part what
makes New Yorkers tough.
We can survive it, you can't
and only in the
last year with COVID
and what Mayor de Blasio,
Governor Cuomo have done,
have I come around to,
I was wrong and these
people are right.
What they've done
to New York City,
the crown jewel of America,
you know, one of the
great cities of all time,
is unforgivable
and unacceptable.
And there's no
possibility, in my opinion,
of things getting
better and I'm curious--
- Ever, you think
they can never?
- In the medium term,
in the medium term.
There's no mechanism
for it to get better.
If I'm a young person and
I want to make a store
that sells like,
artisinal socks, cheeses,
I'm a young restaurateur,
I want to open up a
cool new restaurant,
why would I go into
New York City now,
where every single
regulation is against me,
where I'm being told constantly,
maybe not explicitly,
but implicitly, we
don't want you to here,
you're not welcome.
New York is not
open for business
and we are just going to shut
you down at the drop of a hat.
And I feel as if LA
is kind of similar in that vein,
that it's going to get worse
because there's no mechanism
for it to get better.
I'm curious to hear
your thoughts on that.
- Yeah, well, as you know,
I think LA is an
absolute disaster
and I've only been to
New York once since.
I can't believe I'm talking
to you in this thing.
This is really, you look good.
This is actually the best
you've looked honestly.
- Well, of course, you have
to see my hideous face.
- No, I've only been
to New York once
since this whole thing happened.
I was in Midtown Manhattan
'cause I was doing the Gutfeld
show at Fox and it was scary.
It felt like "I Am Legend".
There were no
business people out.
There are only people
out walking alone
with masks and hats
and it was kind of
cold, so jackets,
and everyone looks kind
of shady and there's cops
and a lot of barricades
and all that stuff.
And it's like, how does
this ever come back?
And here, I mean, you
know, the main, the main...
I want to say
exactly where we are,
but the main drag here still
a ton of boarded up stuff.
What mom and pop shop?
Forget young people,
you said young people,
what person that had
their business closed
in the last year
that is experienced,
maybe even has a little
money, could be like,
yeah let's do it again,
let's do it again
so Newsom can shut
us down next month
when we have the climate
lockdowns or COVID2
or give me something
better than that.
- The only possibility
of things getting better,
I tweeted this this week,
if Caitlyn Jenner runs
on a campaign of hitting
and running Governor Newsom
I think she would get
elected in a landslide.
But here's what people
don't appreciate,
they thought one day Detroit
could never go anywhere.
Not only was Detroit
"Motor City",
the home of the
automobile industry,
the music coming out of Detroit
still resonates decades later,
still legendary decades later.
Now Detroit is a bombed out
shelter, a hole in the ground,
of what it used to be.
Hollywood, in my view,
is running on fumes,
on inertia of the Golden Age.
You know, you go to
LA every pretty girl,
every hunk from their
hometown come, as you did,
comes to Los Angeles to make
their name, to make their mark.
And now the movie industry
doesn't have that cachet.
It's not like the place
you have to be anymore
because thanks to the internet,
there's so many more venues
for young filmmakers,
especially internationally
to, on a small budget,
create and innovate
something amazing.
"Parasite", you know which
came out of South Korea,
won the Academy Award.
There's such a hunger for,
and it's not even a
right or left wing thing,
there's such a hunger for
new voices, new creativity.
But Hollywood and these
media establishment entities
are so corporate, that whether
you're reading a comic book
or you're reading
about the middle ages,
or you're reading about a
documentary, the messaging,
the culture, the punchlines
are all going to be the same.
So why would you come
here, where you can hang up
your shingle and be a filmmaker
and be as, opposed to Hollywood,
and you're going to
have an edge that way?
- We're going out to
dinner after this.
Are you going to be
dressed like this?
- Well, sure.
- How you gonna eat,
how you gonna eat?
- Well, I mean, I'm on a cut.
I'm going to be doing
an underwear ad, so.
- Are you shocked?
So, so look, you
live in Brooklyn.
I was born in Brooklyn
and I've only lived in
New York and now LA.
You're a New Yorker,
a true New Yorker.
Are you shocked how
quickly everybody folded
and that still now, people
I assume in Brooklyn,
are wandering around
with masks outdoors
and the dingbats that
I'm walking by over here,
are doing the same?
- To tell you what
level of New Yorker I am
and the audience,
I don't know how to drive.
So I'm going to have
to learn how to drive.
I am, I am shocked--
- That's a true New Yorker.
That's a true New Yorker.
- This is what
I'm shocked about,
I am shocked to
what level Americans
who have prided themselves
on their sense of defiance,
who in 2016 had an opportunity
to vote for someone,
in large part to
just give the finger
to the corporate press,
how solidly they folded in
the wake of these lockdowns
and were subservient.
And what's even worse,
and this is where it gets
from the point of, okay maybe
you're a little bit weak,
maybe you're a
little bit fearful,
I can wrap my head around that.
I'm not a particular tough
guy, but when you see things
like in Canada, there
was a woman who tweeted,
I'm sure you saw this, I'm
sure many people saw this,
there was a, I think
it was Ontario,
where the message went
out that your children
should be quarantined in a room
in your home for two weeks.
And when I went after this,
people couldn't even believe it.
They assumed I meant just
being locked in your house
with your family,
which isn't ideal,
but it's hardly a nightmare.
And the woman was tweeting
that it was heartbreaking
for her to hear her child
banging on the door saying
mommy I'm lonely or mommy,
whatever it was, I'm scared.
And I'm thinking to myself,
I don't care what your
political persuasion is,
if you or I, or virtually
anyone listening to this.
if you're like at a mall and
there's a child who's lost
and scared, you if
they're not ugly, you stop
and you're like, what's
wrong, how can I help you?
Let's find your mom and dad,
let's keep you entertained
and calm until mom
and dad get here.
This is just humanity 101
and I say this as someone
without any facial features.
So to have people not only
do this, but to post about it
on social media and not
just, you would think that--
I could even wrap my
head around being like,
oh yeah I'm totally doing this
and at home being like, I
don't care what the news says
I'm not going to
not hug my children.
- [Dave] Exactly.
- So I'm an uncle now
I've got two nephews.
I absolutely adore them and
if someone says, you know,
lock them in a
room for two weeks,
we're not having a conversation.
That is you declaring
war in my family.
- So the twisted part,
beyond what the mother's
physically doing to the child,
is the virtue signaling that
she then sends the message out,
oh it's breaking my heart!
What I've had to do
is I jailed my child.
What kind of mental
collapse do you think
we've really had as a society?
It seems almost complete to me.
I mean, there are
some sane people,
of course there are
some same people,
but like, it seems like
we have had just like
a cascading collapse at almost
every level at this point.
- I don't think it's a
question of sanity or insanity.
There's a quote, I use all
the time from H. L. Mencken.
If people don't know who he
is, he was one of the great,
controversialists of
the early 20th century.
He was a newspaperman
when newspapermen
were regarded
correctly as basically,
one step above a sex
worker or a drug dealer,
just really just the dregs of
society, and his quote was,
"The average man does
not want to be free.
"He simply wants to be safe."
And I think a lot of
what you're seeing,
what you referred to as
the virtue signaling,
things in social media, the
exchange, the bargain is,
I will do what you, the
people on the screens,
corporate America,
the politicians tell
me and in exchange,
you are going to tell me
that I don't have to
worry about anything,
how to think of anything,
I need responsibility.
I'm just going to follow
orders and be taken care of.
And what drove them crazy,
to some extent about Trump,
is that they, in a
very literal sense,
didn't know what to do
other than freak out.
They weren't being given
that kind of direct guidance
from the screens that they
coveted it so much under Obama
or even under George W. Bush.
- I tweeted this morning,
a quote that you
often put out there,
which is that we
didn't deserve Trump
or we don't deserve--
- We do not deserve Trump, yes.
- Yeah, do you miss him,
how much do you miss him?
- You know what's really
sad about President Trump
is that he sends out
these press releases
that are basically
tweets, attacking people.
You know, many of the
republican party especially,
seem to be his targets,
especially Liz Cheney,
who I will remind everyone
wants to kill your children.
I'm not even
kidding, this woman--
- And her dad killed
a lot of other people.
- Absolutely, although
you have to admit,
like you have you're really
are kind of like a baller
if you shoot someone in the
face and they apologize to you.
Like that, I got to give
Dick Cheney credit for that.
- Google it if you don't
know what he's talking about.
- Yeah but...
I'm sorry, I lost
my train of thought.
What was the question again?
- Well, Trump's like
do you miss him?
- No, so Trump has been sending
out these press releases
and you're just imagining,
instead of him having his
Blackberry whatever he uses,
to send out these tweets,
he's standing in front of
a fax machine, you know,
age 70 whatever, feeding
these press releases.
(makes mouth noises)
And they're hilarious, but
it's just not the same.
What I found a really sick
and I think many people
in the democratic party as well,
I think 49 attorneys
general have joined
inside this lawsuit is
the Facebook policy of
we're not going to allow
President Trump's voice
to appear on this site.
Now, if it is your belief
that president Trump
incited the worst attack in
American soil since 9/11,
and let's put things
in perspective,
AOC had to see a cop
for five minutes.
I mean, my God, these
people are still in therapy
'cause someone put up their
feet on Nancy Pelosi's desk.
- Now it's the insurrectionists
forgot to bring weapons.
Nobody had a gun and the
only person who got shot
was one of them who happened
to formerly be in the Marines.
- In the most armed country,
or certainly one of the most--
- Forgot to bring the guns.
- In the most armed
countries in the world.
So it's kind of
just amazing how
fragile I think,
these elites have in a
control center control tower
and how easily that
balloon has been burst.
- So how much of that and
the sort of hysteria now
and where nothing makes sense
and Biden obviously
has dementia,
and the whole system
is just like every--
Even today, literally an
hour before we're taping this
I heard Biden is going to
build part of the wall.
It's like, everything is just
an epic amount of bullshit
and it's becoming, I think,
harder and harder for
the average person.
Maybe they want to break--
They either want
to break everybody
or they want
everyone to give up,
maybe that's the same thing
or they want everyone to know,
you know, which way's up.
And what do you think?
I mean, is it, is it
a systemic, systemic,
are they systemically just
trying to break our spirit?
Is that really what's happening?
- Well, I think a large part
of what's kind of the message
is that their memory
lasts like six months.
It's really kind of bizarre.
I'm sure you and I, and many
other people are not alone
in the fact that Jimmy Kimmel
has like George W. Bush on,
where like a few years
ago they'd be talking to,
he's a war criminal,
this guy's literally
the worst president.
I mean, and now, you
know, he's just their pal.
The same people who
think President Trump
was Hitler, right,
and is fascist are
regarding Liz Cheney,
the imperialist warmonger, as
a responsible, sane person.
There's this bizarre
detachment from reality
but that's a good measure
of knowing if your
process is working.
It's much easier to train a
smart dog than a dumb dog.
So if you see all
these educated,
not unintelligent people
targeting the same message,
you know that your process
of programming them
has been working
and this has been going on
for over a hundred years.
You had books by Walter
Littman, Bernays is another one,
and the question was,
and this speaks to
like the early days of
mass media, how do we,
the elites who have an
earned right to rule
and to create order out of chaos
through our regulation
and control,
how do we manufacture
consent and Noam Chomsky,
who's a fellow
anarchist of mine,
had a book on this subject and
his reaction was the best way
to do this is to have strictly
limited area of debate
but strong disagreement
within that area.
So, whereas you and I are,
somebody else might say
let's have the debate
range between one and 10.
They'll have it
between six and seven.
Well, there's infinite
numbers between six and seven,
six and a half, 6.7,
and have everyone argue and
think you can't get outside
this very strictly
limited thing.
And you see all the
time how you know,
the language for
heretic changes.
It's racist, it's
insurrectionist, it's
white supremacist,
it's it's Q Anon.
More people on the
left talk about Q Anon
than I've ever seen on social
media coming from the right.
- I've told this a couple
of times on the show
but I went to a Trump
rally in Beverly Hills.
I went to a few of them.
And at one rally, there was
one woman who was into Q
that came up, you know,
everyone knows me there.
They all come up to me,
everyone says nice things.
This woman comes
up to me, she goes,
"Dave, what do you think
about Q, blah blah?"
And I was like, honestly,
I've never talked
about it on the show.
I haven't paid any attention
to it, I don't know anything.
And she got very at me
'cause she was a Q person,
she grabbed a bull horn
and started screaming
that Dave Rubin's here and
he doesn't believe in Q
and everyone walked away from
her and everybody was like,
Dave what do you think
of that crazy woman?
And it's like, that's
what CNN needs.
They need that crazy woman.
- Yeah, and Justin Amash,
who was a former Congressman,
I'm sure you've probably
talked to him at some point.
He had me speak to a
class that he was teaching
or lecturing at the
University of Chicago.
And the first thing I said
to him is my goal today
is to make you regret this
and I was talking
about public education.
One of the students
went on Twitter
and the point being that the
purpose of public education
isn't to educate children.
It's, in their own words,
to create better citizens.
What that means is to
break young spirits
and make them subservient
or an obedient.
And the girl immediately said,
"How can you be talking
about this conspiracy?"
Well, this word is used,
I never said conspiracy.
This is something that,
is there a conspiracy
among pro-life people
to eliminate abortions?
Is there a conspiracy among
businesses to get tax cuts
and regulatory cuts
that further industry
or to increase regulation,
to keep competition out?
But they just
throw out this word
to mean any kind of organization
that's deleterious
to their interests
and it's a mechanism
to forestall
any kind of future
debate and discussion.
And I got to say, I'm very,
very hopeful for the future
of this country because
there is an increasing amount
of recognition on all sides
of the political spectrum,
that political
discourse and discussion
are becoming close
to impossible.
No one believes each other.
No one trusts each
other's motives
and in my view with very,
very, very good reason.
- Okay, you're giving
me a lot Malice
and I can't even see
your beautiful face.
- I don't have one.
- You're just the faceless
political operative now.
- I'm an MPC, yeah.
- You're complete MPC
that you could have been,
you could have
dressed up as the MPC,
with just full on gray.
- I'm too much of a blue
check to ever be an MPC.
A little inside baseball lingo.
- I got it, I got it.
Well, let's just back up though,
to the mask thing for a second
because I'm still seeing
people wearing masks here
and it seems to me that they've
triggered this fear thing
in people that they're
going to always do this.
They're going to always do this,
where years ago you'd
go to the airport
and you'd see Asian
people wearing masks.
And you were like,
oh, are they sick
or are they protecting
us from being sick
or what's going on here?
Like they'll, they've
now just trained us
to do all these things
and we've broken down
the basic social fabric.
You go to a store,
you barely, you know,
you're wearing a mask,
they're wearing a mask.
You barely look at the
cashier in the eye.
We don't go to movie
theaters anymore.
That we've broke down
all of the stuff.
You don't go to a
bar and sit at a--
I used to love just sitting
at a bar and getting a drink
and talking to somebody or
talking to the bartender.
They've broken all of that
and that's going to have
all sorts of repercussions
that we probably can't
even imagine at this point.
- My buddy, Tom Woods,
he and I did a cartoon
which you referred--
- Yeah, I love it I love it.
- In a second, like he
made the point, he's a dad.
He's got, I think,
five daughters.
He made the point, what about
my three-year-old children
or four-year-old children?
What about dogs?
Like, to live in a
society where you can't
see people smiling at you?
This is something that
has profound and severe
long-term psychological
consequences.
You know, a lot of times people
who are a holier than thou,
smarter than everybody
else, you know,
urban elites make fun
of religious people.
But when you're four
or five years old,
you're basically trained
to think that there are
these invisible demons
everywhere they go outside
and without this
magical piece of fabric
in front of your face,
you're one day away from
killing your grandparents.
This is not a healthy,
psychological message
to tell children, that
you should be afraid
of leaving the house.
- What about how they've
butchered science?
I mean, there's almost nothing--
Even, even me, I mean,
I'm fairly well-read.
I talked to some
interesting people.
I'm pretty much
completely skeptical
of anyone that says
anything about science.
You say the word
science and I'm like,
what are you talking about?
I mean, that Faucian effect,
has destroyed the
complete ability
for anyone to believe anything,
at least in my opinion.
- Well, I mean, it's
even broader than that
because we're being
told every five years
we have 10 years
to save the planet
and the only way to
save it is to basically,
destroy all industry.
And even if that happens,
we're still not going
to save it anyway,
but we should still
do it for some,
you know, dubious purpose.
So the goalposts keep changing
and I think I've mentioned
this previously on the show,
I know I've spoken of it before,
this goes back to the
early days of progressivism
and Woodrow Wilson, because
one of the things that happened
during the Great War was
this the big, if I can,
pardon my French,
progressive wet dream,
which is we're going to have
Washington as this super state
governing every single
aspect of our country,
of our economy, of our culture.
Now they had an excuse,
it was the Great War.
This is, you know, world
war, everyone's involved
but this was a great
dress rehearsal
for the Great
Depression, the New Deal,
because they can say,
look, 15 years ago
you guys all did this.
You guys handed over all
your authority to the state,
to Washington.
This is a bigger crisis
than the Great War
and that's actually true.
Like in terms of which is
a bigger threat to America,
the Great Depression or the hun?
It was certainly the,
the Great Depression.
And, you know, I tweeted
this out, I think a year ago,
some very, like it or
not, wrongly or rightly,
whatever the science is,
some very, very bad people
have a lot of very
useful information
about how much people will
put up with these lockdowns
and they could use that
information in the future
and they're not going to
use it for nice things.
- Right, so what do you
think comes after this?
You've had a pretty
good track record
on projecting all of this
and I think you have a
good sense of the general--
- One of the things I am--
I'm very optimistic
about the future,
as I said earlier in
the show and in general,
when I'm optimistic
I think optimism
has to be based on data.
It's not just like
everything's going to be fine.
That is not the case.
There's many cases where
things are not fine
or they're only fine after
a very long period of time.
One of the things I am
shocked and delighted by
is how many people on the
right, especially conservatives,
have seen the cops
for what they are.
As you know, I'm an anarchist.
I could not have a worse
opinion of the police
but they are understanding
that the police are
not their friends.
The police will follow any
law that is being passed
and when these conservatives
start defending the police
I ask them, how much
money would it take you
or would it take for
Gretchen Whitmer to force you
to lock an old
person in their home?
How much money would it
take for Andrew Cuomo
to tell you to keep someone
away from their dying mother
in a hospital?
So there it's a
question of conscience.
If you're going to
just follow orders,
if you're going to
waive the basic element
of what separates us
from the lower animals,
this sense of right and wrong,
and we see it in city
after city, after city.
The police stand down
and the only people
who are punished are
those who have guns
or those who are trying
to defend themselves
or their communities.
In fact, we saw, I believe
it was in Portland,
when the Attorney General Barr,
sent in federal troops
to guard the courthouse.
He was the one who was
hauled before Congress
on having to explain himself
how dare you send in troops
to defend federal property
from being destroyed.
It's a complete Kafkaesque
upside down world.
- So how much damage has
to happen to these cities
before something turns around,
either through the people
or through better governance?
I suppose I know that's
not really your thing,
but like does Portland
have to just completely
become ground zero?
Does Seattle have to collapsed?
Does New York City,
does LA, San Francisco?
Like what actually, do
you think, has to happen
at the human level
that gets people going,
okay we got to turn this around
or does everyone just
have to flee the cities?
- I think what we're
seeing for the first time
in American history,
since America has become
like a worldwide
cultural institution,
starting like the early
1900s to some extent,
is you're having creative
types fleeing these liberal,
you know, currently democratic
areas like LA, New York
and everyone's
moving to red states,
to Austin to Miami
and a few others.
This has never happened
before, where the creativity
goes to the republican party
and I don't see how
you reverse that trend.
Is the question
gonna be, you know,
how did LA get destroyed,
to quote Hemingway,
two ways gradually
and then suddenly.
I don't see a mechanism
or even a desire
because when people
complain in these cities
about how how hard it is
and Cuomo's a great
example of this.
There was a a press conference
during this whole COVID
thing and he was asked like,
you know how you, you know,
you're destroying
these small businesses
and very flippantly,
he was like, well,
if I have to choose between
a lot of people dying
and a lot of businesses
going out of business,
it's not an easy choice
but it's also in one sense,
not a hard choice.
So there's not even like,
a sense of hand-wringing,
what have we done,
what has the cost been?
Because it's very useful
for the corporate media
to not speak about trade-offs.
Thomas Sowell, who I adore, and
you're obviously a huge fan,
talks about instead of
thinking about like,
good or bad, at what costs
and compared to what?
To talk about
costs and benefits.
But they don't want to think
about costs and benefits.
They don't want to think,
okay, this is a good thing
but it's expensive or
this will help this group
but it's hurting
these 10 other groups.
It's more like it's
the right thing to do.
Don't ask any questions.
And like, if something
is the right thing to do,
in the short term that's
certainly a possibility.
What are going to be
the longterm costs
and how do we fix it?
They were tripping
over themselves in 2008
to bail out the banks.
And every little business
that I loved in New York,
stores had been around
since the '70s, the '50s,
they're boarded up, the
signs are still there
'cause they were proud, this
is a family institution.
They're gone and they're
never coming back
and no one cares.
- Do we have to jail
some of these people?
I mean, is that like the
end that basically Cuomo
and Whitmer and Newsom,
that it's very obvious
there was no science
behind the lockdowns.
They decided to destroy
millions of lives--
- [Michael] Killed the elderly.
- I think it literally kill
the elderly in Cuomo's case
and in probably
in Witmer's case.
- Well not probably, let's
talk about that video.
I'm sorry to interrupt you,
but that video that went viral,
there was this kid I
think he was 17, 18, 19
was in a nursing home and
was beating up elderly people
in their beds and posting
it on social media.
This went viral.
- Oh, was that in Michigan?
I know--
- It was Michigan, yes.
- Okay, okay, okay.
- He was in those homes
because by law, it was mandated
they're going to be quarantining
them in these locations.
So it's not, maybe she was
killing person after person
and I have, I'm sure
you saw this on Twitter.
If you go to
governorstogitmo.com,
I've got the t-shirts to that's
my answer to this problem.
- Right, but really--
- Just one more thing, I'm
sorry to interrupt you.
It's not going to change until
politicians have consequences
on a personal level for their
malfeasance and depravity.
I don't know what
that looks like,
but it's certainly more
than them getting voted
out of office.
This cannot continue and I
think they're pushing America
in a very dangerous direction.
Brinksmanship is
something that very rarely
has a happy ending.
- Well, it's like every
day now in California,
Newsom's coming out and
we're giving you stuff,
more money for you guys.
And it's like, wait a minute.
How do progressive suddenly
think giving us money is good?
I thought that taxes are bad
but it's all the tax
money you took from us
in the first place.
I mean, I know none of it
really makes any sense.
But okay, if voting
them out's not enough,
I mean really, what do you
think either the jailing
or like what, are we going to
send them to the phantom zone?
Like, what are we going
to do with these people?
(Michael laughs)
I'm okay with the Phantom.
So, but really like,
what's the real thing
because these people
deserve none of our respect
or attention or money
or power or anything.
- I think something
that's very--
You just hit the
nail on the head.
One of the things that President
Trump did very, very well
and there's a lot of things
he didn't do so well,
is he demonstrated
that these people
should not be
treated with respect
but be treated with
open brazen contempt.
If you are telling me that
I cannot hug my child,
if you are telling me
that I can't see my mother
breathe her last breath
in this hospital,
this is not like, well,
I've got one opinion,
you've got another opinion,
let's just kind of hash it
out and agree to disagree.
This is completely in
my view, beyond the pale
and the time for
conversation has ended.
And the thing is,
the republicans need
to go on offense
instead of constantly
having to apologize
and discuss the
hard left's idea.
Here's one example, everyone
now in this country,
who's politically
minded has an opinion
on whether we should
defund the cops, right?
Everyone talked
about it, everyone,
most people are against it,
but everyone discussed it.
Why is no one discussing
ending birthright citizenship?
My personal idea is to have
a, using the second amendment,
and using the
logic of Obamacare,
make gun ownership mandatory.
The second amendment says
a well-regulated militia,
which means a militia of
citizens who are regulated,
who are informed and practiced
in the use of their firearms
is necessary for free people.
So either you get a gun or you
can't vote, things like this.
Now the New York Times
is going to freak out.
The Washington Post
Don Lemon is going to you
know, have a meltdown on air.
That's going to
happen regardless.
Anne Coulter had
this great quote,
where she says
attention republicans,
if the New York times
isn't calling you racist,
you're losing.
- For the record for the
record, for the record, eh?
Called me a white supremacist
this week, pretty good.
- Did they really?
- Well, they asked Andrew Yang
why he goes on white
supremacist shows, in effect me.
Actually, they called it
"The Dave Rubin Show".
This is the "Rubin Report".
I couldn't even get
them to retract that.
I didn't even care about
the white supremacy part.
I was like, ah, you know,
we've done that a
million times already
but they got the name
of the show wrong.
They wouldn't even fix that.
- But you know what
else is amazing?
- It's an honor.
- It's also amazing that
you would ask a politician
why would you want
to promote your views
on a place that has an audience?
It's really funny
'cause on the one hand
you have the Maxine Waters types
and I do like her
antagonism and aggression,
I'm not going to lie,
but she's saying,
if you see something from
the Trump administration
at the gasoline
station, at the mall,
you go up to them and you
say you're not welcome here.
I would, you would
expect them to,
if you are a white supremacist,
if you're a homophobe,
if you're an anti-Semite,
all these things,
which we know you are,
to come here and be like,
screw you, Dave Rubin,
you're terrible,
your ideas are horrible,
you're this, you're that
and so on and so forth.
That you want to take
the fight to the enemy!
- Malice, this is why
I love you, Malice.
This is a great point.
- Where is he?
- It's somewhere over here.
Yeah, it's over there.
It's a great point.
On one hand, they're
saying, get in their faces,
don't let them have an
inch, blah, blah, blah,
and then on the other hand,
they're saying don't talk
to them at all and
pretend they don't exist.
- And we saw a great
example of this
when Brian Stelter from
CNN, he had a panel
and they were freaking out
that venues like Tim Pool,
like your show, Joe
Rogan, several others,
have bigger audiences as
CNN and people are getting
the wrong information,
by which they mean
information they don't like,
and what are we going
to do about this?
So their agenda is
basically, well,
let's pretend the Dave
Rubin don't exist,
that Tim Pool don't exist.
Well, that became too hard.
Your audience is too big.
Your social media
following is too big.
Now it's like, well
on individual level,
maybe we'll starve
him out of guests.
You have no shortage of
people, idiots from Brooklyn
you know, dressing like
question banging down your door
to try to get on the show.
So that's not
really going to work
but it shows their desperation
and the fact that they're
running out of ideas.
- So then what's after that?
Because I've been saying
for a while I mean,
all of us have a limited
window on social media.
I'm thrilled that I think
you were the second guy
on local basically and
you're killing it on there.
But it seems to me
that because of exactly
what you just said there,
that the jig is up.
They've been exposed.
Everyone gets it.
They can't let us on YouTube
and Twitter and
Facebook much longer.
Like it just can't,
it's not tenable.
- But I've always said
there's going to have to be
alternative sources for people
and our culture has to defricate
in order to go forward.
Back in the day, it
was ABC, NBC, CBS.
Now in terms of news,
there's literally
thousands of sources.
Some of them are
completely wrong
and misinformation and kookie.
Some of them, it's a spectrum.
Some are, you know, objective
and spot on the money.
The only way the New York Times
can be the New York Times,
in terms of stature, is if
it has close to monopoly
on the microphone.
And I don't see how
like Humpty Dumpty,
once that egg is shattered,
how you put it back
together again.
We're never going to
be again as a country.
It's not even in terms
of the with the news.
Look at like the
M.A.S.H. finale.
Kids, there was a
show called M.A.S.H.,
which is about the Korean War.
- What was the number, what
was the number on the finale?
60 million or something, yeah.
- But even the Super Bowl.
- This was something that
everyone, air-quotes,
in America is watching.
You can't get that together
in terms of the New York Times
or even CBS, ABC,
NBC news anymore.
Our country has
become too split up
and that's, choice is
the basis of liberalism.
That's what liberalism means.
You have as many options
and you're free to choose
as you wish.
But this is a big threat
because their entire worldview
is based on their
depravity and malfeasance.
They're more upset that
someone had their feet up
on Nancy Pelosi's desk, that
many people in the elites
were possibly engaging
in statutory rape
with Jeffrey Epstein and
ABC news knew about this
and didn't inform
the authorities.
- But the guy had his feet up.
He was wearing his shoes.
He took a picture.
I mean--
- Were they seal leather?
- They were not as fancy as
your shoes, that's for sure.
So, at what point do you think
we've crossed the Rubicon here?
Have we crossed the
valley, let's say,
where we should just
start ignoring them.
I struggle with
this all the time--
- [Michael] No.
- Okay, go ahead.
- The battle is won when
the average American
regards a corporate journalist
exactly as they regard
a tobacco executive.
Now, whenever I say this, some
mid wit has to get on Twitter
and say the tobacco
executive's much better.
Yeah, I said regards, and
that is the next step.
You have to realize I'm not
Catholic, you're not Catholic.
I like the Pope.
Some of the popes I
like, some I don't like.
You could hear him out
but there's no reason
for me to believe
everything he says
or to trust him to some
exceptional degree.
So the thing is, there's
no reason the same way,
to believe CNN, Fox, NBC.
These are corporate
entities with an agenda
and if you're at a
point where Coca-Cola
is telling their employees
to be less racist,
given Coca-Cola's
extremely racist history--
- Right, they sort of backed
off this thing though, right?
They, didn't they delete
some of the diversity
and inclusion stuff?
- And that's the point.
Like now they are
trying their shenanigans
but people are onto them
and instead of trying
to have this lively debate,
it's like we're not
having this conversation.
This is just a mechanism
for you to further you power
and we're going to
have to fight back
because I am not going to
bend the knee to your nonsense
any longer, especially because
constantly and explicitly
you're coming for our children.
- Do you think it's possible
that they've awoken a real
lion here, like a real beast
and I mean that
in the best sense,
that I just tweeted this out
in the last couple of hours,
something about like
we need rallies again.
Like the Trump rallies were so
much joy, so much positivity,
so much true diversity
and all of that stuff.
And I'm not saying it
has to be Trump doing it.
I personally wouldn't have a
problem if it was, but like,
do we just need,
like, they in effect,
they've awoken something
that we must get out there
and show them that we're here.
That that's the only way and
they locked us in our houses
to make sure we couldn't do it.
- You know why--
- While they bowed
at protestors.
- Those rallies are a grand
air for the simple reason
that it's an symbol of defiance.
Everyone remembers how
Governor Abbott of Texas,
he rescinded some
of these mandates.
Governor Newsom in
California tweeted out
that it was unacceptable
or I don't remember
what term he used,
but he was basically
condemning it.
Nothing happened
as a consequence
and everyone pretended
it didn't happen.
So if you have
these big rallies,
which they're going
to be described
as white supremacist rallies,
they're going to describe
it that way anyway,
and this is showing people
we're not gonna stand
six feet apart from each other
and no one's going to
die as a consequence.
We're going to be safe and,
and so on and so forth.
That kind of element
of defiance is useful
because people in the middle,
there's something called
the bandwagon effect.
People in the middle are,
who don't really have
a political opinion
one way or another,
but basically--
You know, all my life,
I'm a New Yorker.
I'm not a sports fan.
People be like Yankees
or Mets, I would say Mets
'cause I like the blue
and the orange better.
I literally have no other
mechanism for choosing.
But if you have no
mechanism for choosing,
you're going to go to the
people who are having fun.
You're going to go to the
people who have the energy.
So if you have one group
that's like be miserable,
never go to a concert
and the other one's like,
don't you want to have
like rock and roll
and listen to even
Elvis, it's like, yeah,
I'm going to go to where
the people having fun are
and that's a big threat
to their control.
- So in many ways, this is
what you would have wanted
to happen a long time
ago at some level, right?
That the right, the new right,
to use the title of your book
that the new right
would become the place
that was creative and cool
and there would be music
and parties and fun and
sex and all of those things
that humans are supposed to do.
And all the left
has, is preening,
fake morality and
hysteria and lunacy.
- I mean, I'm going to
be a little bit pedantic
and I apologize.
I wouldn't call
it fake morality.
They really have a very
strict puritanical morality
which is--
- Well, I meant fake
meaning it's not moral
in a objective sense.
- No, it is moral an objective
sense in the sense that like,
a morality, let's get
my Yaron Brook hat on,
morality in the Ayn
Rand sense is basically
a code of ethics
or code of values,
which governs every
aspect of your life.
Keeping kosher in the Jewish
ethic is a good example
of acting ethically.
Every choice you make
with your food is guided
by this ethical code
and they've extended that
to literally every aspect
of your life.
Who you sleep with, what
kind of food you eat.
It's got to be ethical,
local, so on and so forth.
How you dress, what
shows you watch,
who you interview
on your own set.
It's, it's just amazing
to what extent--
This is the other
thing I point out,
if you're talking, I talk
discussed about this in my book,
if you're talking about
video games, scifi,
fantasy, comic books,
places where people go
to escape reality
and escape the earth
and have this kind of
sense of adventure,
their morality and their
worldview even permeates there.
There's nowhere on
earth, space, time
or the future where you can
go to escape their edicts
and at a certain point,
many people are like,
I don't want to live like this.
I want to judge my friends
on are they going to be there
for me when I have a tragedy
or not who they voted for
or whether they think Trump
is Hitler as opposed to maybe
they think he's just a buffoon.
- How much further will
they crack down then, right?
They're not going to
just give up, like,
okay so we start rallies again.
We're creating good stuff.
We're doing all the stuff that
you would like to see happen
and by the way, I do think
it's happening, right?
- Oh yes.
- It is happening.
There's no doubt about it,
but they're not
just gonna give up.
They're not just
going to walk away.
And even when Coke reverses
slightly its diversity stuff
it's like, well, what
are you really saying?
Yesterday you were telling
half your employees
that they're racist, now you
got exposed so they're not?
Like...
- I remember last year--
- [Dave] What do
we do with this?
- I said the riots are
about 72 hours away
from having corporate
sponsorship.
And it was like,
like two hours later,
everyone's bending over
backwards to endorse these,
the civil unrest
- PlayStation!
I literally turned on my
PlayStation and it offered me
a free Black Lives Matter
background on there.
- Right, but it's
amazing to what, right.
So everything has to be
permeated with this very speci--
And it's not only like,
it would be one thing
if they had said, we want people
to value black lives more.
It specifically just has
to be this one slogan.
And this month we're only caring
about black people.
Next month we're caring
about this group,
next month we're caring
about this group.
And if you're a poor white
person and you're resentful,
well you had your turn, you
know, go home and suck it up.
So I don't think
this is something
that's going to be able
to last much longer.
And I have to give credit
to people on the left,
people like James Carville,
Van Jones and some others,
where they're like
this is something
that cannot long-term
sustain itself.
And Britain of all places,
I mean talk about just terms
of backward s-hole.
They just had their
local elections
after having a new
leader for labor,
which is when their two
main parties, Sir Keir,
and he was much
more to the center
than their previous
leader, Jeremy Corbyn.
They had their
off year elections
and they were seeing
their biggest losses
since like World War II.
So if you're, and you're
seeing this also in Germany.
The social Democrats,
which are historically,
the second biggest
party in Germany,
are now polling
at like 11 or 12%.
So in country after
country, this old coalition
of the left being the
party of the labor unions,
the working man, they
now have such contempt
for the working man, especially
in America since Reagan.
When you had union workers
who are voting republican
they just threw themselves,
they've got thrown
into the garbage as
quickly as possible.
And this is what I think people
on the right don't understand.
They don't care about
Muslim immigrants,
Mexican people at the
border, transgender rights,
it's whatever group is
of use at the moment
to further their agenda
and once that group
is not behaving or acting
in the way that they like,
they're just swiftly discarded.
Here's a great example
that's not even an
identity politics group.
Everyone can look up
and probably remembers
they had these stopping
bullying campaigns.
All the nerds getting
shoved into lockers,
we need to put a stop to
this, this is terrible.
This is not who we
are as a country.
True.
Then came Gamergate and the
nerds were the first ones
to fight back.
- The nerds fought back.
Do you think it's all
really connected to that?
- The nerds fought back.
They were like, we're not, we
just want to play video games.
We don't care about identity
politics in Star Wars
and all the narrative now
became that those people
who play video games
are not only racist,
but are potential
school shooters.
Two years ago let's
not bully them,
now they're an existential
threat to this country
and the world.
- Did it all start there
with the Gamergate thing?
- That was the first time
where you had a group
that just wanted to
mind their own business
and they realized--
- And the entire machine.
- Yeah, they will
not leave us alone.
We just want to sit at
home in our underwear,
eating our Cheetos,
with our headphones
and our VR station
playing this dopey game
and even in my basement
where I have no friends
I still can't escape
you and your clutches.
- Woo, Malice, Malice!
We got, we got a
lot of stuff to fix.
Let's jump back
for just a second
because you said something
about the Democrats not being
or in effect the left,
not being the party
of the working man, but, but
they want $15 minimum wage.
Wouldn't that be the greatest
thing for the working man?
That doesn't that mean they care
about the working man, Malice?
I'm smiling as I say this to you
- In terms of the minimum wage,
I am one of the few
people who are anarchist
who are in favor
raising minimum wage
because I cannot handle
dealing with cashiers.
All their job is is to
input mistakes between me
and the touch screen.
And listen, if the
minimum wage in effect,
gives people more money
and doesn't hurt jobs,
I'm all for it.
But it really--
- But you know that
it's not true, right?
- And the minimum wage is zero,
and it's always gonna be zero.
No one ever expected
that a minimum wage--
One of the things you see
these tropes on social media
is that a minimum
wage job can't pay
for a one bedroom apartment.
Yeah, it's called minimum.
A minimum wage job should pay
for the minimum size apartment.
That's just the logic to it.
And minimum wage jobs
have never been designed
for someone to
provide for a family.
It's for people
who are marginal,
it's people who are teenagers,
people who are in need
of getting out of prison
or something trying to get
their feet on the ground,
people who used to be
homeless or unemployed
or people who really
just are struggling
and they're trying
to make their way
through night school or
building up the resources
in other capacities, in terms
of their career or the resume.
So--
- But can you give me the
true anarchist version
of just why the government
has no right to tell you
how much you have
to pay somebody?
Give me like your pure
anarchist one-on-one version.
- You just did it.
- Oh, I know I did it, but I
was trying to be a good host
and let you do it, you know.
- All government edicts have
no authority whatsoever,
just because a bunch of
people in Philadelphia
had a conspiracy and
found a signed of paper,
the fact that that is going
to have to have an impact
between my relationship
with you in terms of
how much money I'm offering
you for your services
or your book or your shoes
or anything like that,
there's absolutely no role
for the state to get involved
in a situation like that.
And it's the poor
people who are always
the first ones that be
hurt and this is why
corporate America
loves the minimum wage.
I'm Wal-Mart, I'm Target,
I can afford to pay my workers
at the very bottom more
but that little store, where
that one extra employee
is the difference between
having two people, mom and dad
and three, that's a 50% increase
in terms of my productivity,
I'm the one who's
going to be screwed.
- Sorta like how the
lockdowns allowed
for Target to remain open but
the little mom and pop store
that sells the same stuff
as Target next door,
wasn't allowed to remain open
by the orders of the democrats.
- We have seen a
systemic assault on
middle-class businesses
by corporate America, both
in terms of them cheering on
the literal physical
destruction in terms of looting
and rioting and saying
it's mostly peaceful.
Meanwhile, COVID remember
they're saying was like,
93% of these protests
are peaceful.
Well, COVID has a
99% survival rate,
and we had to shut
down the Earth!
(Dave laughs)
So, you laugh, but the--
- Science, math, come on!
- They say whatever
is of use to them
in that moment to
further their power
and they will never apologize
for being called out
on their crap.
Here's another good example,
that is transcends partisan
political lines.
We were told in
2020, early 2020,
that there is about to be a
genocide of the Kurds in Syria
and then if we don't have
American troops there tomorrow,
boots on the ground, this is
going to be another Holocaust.
We did not have
boots on the ground.
The Kurds have not been
exterminated as a race.
- Trump got us out.
- And no one who was arguing
for killing American soldiers
had any shame or consequences
for what they had
been advocating.
- Speaking of no shame
and consequences,
I think you went after him on
Twitter so I will bring it up
'cause I had to do it too, even
though he's been on my show.
But David Frum, in the
last couple of days,
with everything going on in
Israel and he starts going off
on Trump, look at
those Trump peace deals
that didn't accomplish anything.
This is the man
who literally wrote
the axis of evil speech that
lied us into the Iraq war.
Part of all of it is that
they have no shame, right?
Like what do you think that
is psychologically, actually?
Is it just self preservation?
- It is a very sad thing
to be closer to your coffin
than to your prime, as a man.
And it is a sad testament to
the history of this country
how we treated women, how
we treated minorities,
how we treated gay people,
that all the appropriate
words to describe David Frum
have misogynist or
homophobic context.
- You're good,
Malice, you're good.
Let's back up to something
you said earlier,
you mentioned Van Jones
and who was the other one?
James Carville.
- James Carville.
- As sort of the
democrats or lefties,
who were kind of trying to
do something from the inside.
You know, a little bit of
the history of Dave Rubin.
I tried it, as a lefty.
I wrote a book
defending liberalism
and how it's different
than leftism.
I'm the why I left the left guy.
You think they have any chance?
Like what do you
make of those people
trying to do that
thing at this point?
- Let me say something
that's going to make
some conservatives very upset.
Corporate democrats
have been a lot better
and stronger at defeating
the hard left in 2020
than the republicans were.
Joe Biden's nomination
was the democratic party
getting into felons with Danny
Chloachar with Kamala Harris
with Pete Buttigieg saying
Biden's the nominee.
You're folding your
campaign today.
You're getting on a plane today.
You're endorsing Biden
and he got the nomination.
- Wait, wait, can I
pause you for one second?
So just to be clear,
so they all did that the
day before Super Tuesday,
so that the next day,
in effect that Tuesday,
Biden would basically
get the nominee
although he has turned
out to be far worse,
you would agree right?
- Than who?
- Than what.
Like how much
worse could this be
if Bernie was in
charge right now?
I think you could argue
it's actually worse
because he came in cloaked,
as opposed to being
obvious what it was.
- That's a very interesting
conversation to have
and you can easily in my view.
- No, I'm doing
an interview show.
- No, but I'm saying I can
easily argue for both sides.
It's very nuanced.
Do you want someone who
is honest, an idiolog
or is it easier to get over
if you're kind of passing
as being in the middle?
How much of this
is Biden's ideas?
How much of it is the ideas
that you have behind him?
I find it hilarious
that the leaders
of Black Lives Matter publicly
said Biden and Kamala Harris
won't even take our calls.
They hadn't even
been inaugurated yet.
It was just an amazing
thing to watch.
So this is, but the thing is,
I think people in the right
tend to regard the
democratic party
and the left as a monolith.
It's the same people
who would tell you that,
I mean, if someone told you
that Jeb Bush is the same thing
as Trump is the same
thing as Hitler,
you're on the right,
you're all republicans,
it's just nonsensical
and Van Jones, as you
mentioned, is a good example.
He's a former communist,
literal communist,
but the commies really often
have this red pill perspective
'cause they understand how
corporate politics work.
They understand the
interrelationship between
corporate America and
the political process
and how the little
guy's always the one
that gets gets screwed.
- So where do you think guys
like them end up at this point?
- [Michael] What do you mean?
- Where does a
guy like Van, Joe,
like the guys that
are still on the left
that are trying to negotiate
with the woke thing,
trying to make sense
of Biden, like,
you know, the few that
are still somewhat sane
in the midst of this.
Where do you think
they sort of end up,
do they end up where I'm at?
- There's a few--
Let me ask you a question
to segue with this,
there's a few scenarios.
One is they win and they
basically purge the party
or marginalize these loons
and have them just be
in the garbage can or--
- Okay, let's say that's
not going to happen.
- Or they're driven
out of the party,
or they're the ones
who are marginalized.
But this has been going on
since the '90s at least.
The Clintons with the DLC,
the democratic leadership
council I believe it's called
or whatever it's called.
The idea was we're going to
be the new moderate democrat.
He did balance the
budget, against his will.
He did limit spending,
against his will.
Passed the ban on gay marriage,
which is a conservative idea.
So Bill Clinton in many
ways, is better at delivering
ostensibly conservative ideas
than many of of the
republicans ever were.
So I think politics is
often counterintuitive,
in terms of who's the vehicle
who's going to deliver
the goods that you want.
Richard Nixon brought about
a laundry list of leftist
wish dreams, including
rules and price controls
which even Bernie Sanders
isn't advocating for.
- Right.
What about the, we
talked a little bit--
- So let me ask
you that question.
You tell me, what is the
process when you start out,
as James Carville, who
I'm sure would have been
somewhere close to your
world view at the time.
He's a savvy Democrat,
he's a tactician,
he's a strategist, but now,
you know, you voted for Trump.
What were the steps?
If you sat down with Dave
Rubin or a Dave Rubin
at that time, to get
you from there to voting
for someone who you might've
perceived as Hitler?
- Well, I think the final step,
and I'll give you
the final step first.
The final step for me
of being okay with Trump
is that I actually met
the guy at Mar-a-Lago
and that when he was
introduced to David and I,
and realized that David was
my husband, and he said,
"Gay, gay," and he slapped
the table and stood up
with this huge smile and
shook our hands and thanked us
for being there and then
turned to Melania and said
you know, can you believe
it, these guys are gay.
Their only problem is
they're they're too handsome.
It wasn't that he
was complimenting me.
It was that an illusion about
him was exploded in front
of my face in real time.
And it was like, well,
wait a minute, if that,
if I was still hung up on maybe
he's anti-gay or something
or that a lot of people
still walk around thinking
that Trump's racist, that
Trump is truly racist.
The who was--
- Here's a better example.
If you're a Nazi, his
daughter converted to Judaism
and I'm going to be
very, very serious.
We're sitting here as two Jews,
to divorce Nazi-ism from
antisemitism is despicable
and in any other context, people
who are students of history
realize this is very,
very wrong to regard these
as separate concepts
and separate phenomenon.
They go hand in hand.
So to refer to someone as a
Nazi when they welcome Jews
into their own family,
converted Jews,
is really marginalizing the
oppression of many people
who are relatives
of ours in the past.
- And by the way, these are
the same people who run around
screaming about cultural
appropriation all the time.
And they're doing the
most, in some ways,
you could argue the
most horrific type
of cultural appropriation.
But to answer your question,
well you know, I mean,
it was a long slog for
me but it wasn't just,
it, wasn't just
waking up to ideas
and reading Thomas Sowell
and actually sitting
down with him
and meeting Trump and
sitting down with him
and then talking to guys
like you and realizing
when I sat down, suddenly
with Prager and with Shapiro
and Glenn Beck and all
these people who not on--
Yeah, we kind of agreed
to disagree on some stuff
that yes, I've shifted in
their way at some level,
obviously, but it was like they
were nicer and more generous
and more lively where the
left everyone's afraid
of their shadow and
people turn on each other.
And it's, it's very unpleasant.
And most of my friends
on that side actually,
I've realized aren't that great.
And I found this other
thing that's very
intellectually robust and
interesting and fun and real.
So it's a long freaking
slog, but I would say it's,
it's not just the
political part.
It's, it's both
those parts together.
- What were your concerns and
were those concerns accurate?
Because you were, you know,
if you become an apostate
in any ideology, you're a big
target because if we lose one,
maybe this Martin Luther, right.
If we lose this guy, we might
be losing a lot of people.
- The signal, the
signal gets out there.
Well, look, I mean, look,
Candace walked away also,
I walked away plenty of,
but now there's a whole
walkway movement, but
I mean you've seen
my Twitter responses, like
the endless barrage of hate
from the people who
purport to be tolerant.
I mean, you know, and
I've lost friends.
I've had problems with,
there are family members
who won't talk to me right now.
- Is that true?
- Oh yeah.
Like close family members
that won't talk to me.
Like, you know, the, just
the endless, the crazy types.
I'll give you one.
I had a lifelong friend who I
met at a bar in New York City
a couple of years ago.
We actually went to our, we
knew each other from childhood,
went to college together,
studied political
science together,
played basketball
together over the years
we always did this, this
thing that we're doing
we always did this
about everything, right.
I meet him at a bar.
It was obvious that our politics
were going in
different directions,
but this was before I
had said I was going
to vote for Trump and we get--
He's immediately
just attacking me,
that we hadn't seen
each other in years.
He had just had a new kid,
which I wanted to talk about.
I didn't want to do politics.
He's just attacking me over
and over and over again
and finally I said
to him, I said,
"Do you think it's possible
that I believe what I believe
"as much as you believe
what you believe?"
and without hesitation,
he said, "No."
And I thought that level
of certitude is something
that I want nothing to do with.
- But also the sense
that you can imagine
someone saying this and
then as soon as the words
come out of their mouth
you know, like something,
like if I'm making fun of
somebody I'll go too far
and I hear it and I'm
like whoa, I'm sorry Dave.
I didn't..
- I didn't mean it
that way, but no!
- And you would
catch yourself, like,
what have I become?
Here's the other, I'm sorry,
to keep interrupting you.
- Just to add one other
thing, which is that,
when you shed all
of those friends,
look, I'd rather be
hated for who I am
than loved for who I'm not.
And it becomes obvious,
it sounds like a cliche
when you say it,
but then it really is
something that's real
and when realize that
you're standing up
on your own two feet and
that you see the world
in a certain way
and here I am in it,
people are gonna hate me
for it or love me for it
or whatever, but
it's better to be me
than to be someone
else to be liked.
I mean, it's like the oldest
story in the book, right.
- Unconditional love
means unconditional.
It does not mean conditioned
on who you would prefer
to have as president, which
will have very little impact
in your day to day life anyway.
Let me just ask you one
more question, if I may,
you know, being the
guest in your show,
can you compare to me your
thought process and your fears
about coming out as gay
on September 10th, 2001
and coming out as
being right of center,
because you're also in very
different parts of your life.
You know, you're
younger here, you know,
you don't have the
financial stability.
You don't have the
platform necessarily.
Here you're older.
- This was a million
times harder.
It's not even close.
Politically, I'm talking about
rather than coming out as gay.
I was 25 then yes, I
had internal tumult.
Some which, by the
way, the ghosts of that
live with me at 44.
Like, that's just how life is.
But it was like
an internal thing.
And by the way, when I
started coming out to people,
everybody reacted great.
There were one or two
little family things.
One or two, people were shocked.
I don't, I don't act gay,
that's what everyone kept
telling me, I don't act gay.
They don't really see
me after 10:00 p.m.,
but you know what I mean?
Not that. (laughs)
But it was in essence, it
was all love and affirmation
and great be who you
are and like, fantastic,
this is amazing and wonderful.
This thing of doing this,
it's an endless reckoning,
where David now gets
messages on Facebook,
that he's married,
from friends of his,
saying that they can
no longer be friends
with him because he's
married to a Nazi
or a lot of people
were messaging him,
I mean a sizeable amount of
people, former friends of his,
you're married to a terrorist
after the January 16,
which obviously I had
nothing to do with,
and I wasn't there
and blah, blah, blah.
But that ongoing level of
hate and to be here in LA,
where I know that, you
know, I'm living in a city
that's not congruent
with my beliefs.
And when I go out, you
know, most of the people
that say hi to me are nice,
but you don't know what
anyone else is thinking
and we also live in a
time with weird, you know,
anything goes politically
and you're allowed
to smash people over
the heads with bottles
and throw them out
without cocktails.
So like that ain't fun.
So this has been way, way hard.
- I would tell all the young
people listening to this
who are scared of coming out--
- But better!
- No, but I'll tell
them if you, you're,
'cause the concern
is, and it's not,
it's a realistic concern,
if you come out as
something gay, republican,
whatever it is, I'm going to
lose a bunch of friends, right?
You want to lose that friend.
It's better to be hungry and
looking for your next meal
or looking for peers
who like you as you.
It's gonna be tough
in the medium term.
It's gonna be very tough,
than to be trapped in a cage,
where you're fed like a
little tablet every day
or trapped in a social
group where you,
if these people knew
who you really were
they wouldn't like
you or respect you.
That is you can live
like that forever.
You are never going to be
happy and most importantly,
you are not going
to be able to look
at yourself in the mirror.
And having that
capacity to be like,
I am living true to my values
and my friends like me,
not despite them,
but because of them,
to me that goes hand
in hand with happiness,
success and self esteem.
And when you're that kind of
person who stands up strong
and is like, this is what
I think this is who I am.
That is very attractive
in a business sense,
in a romantic sense,
and in a social sense.
- Malice, are you saying
that we should all stand up
straight with our
shoulders back?
Somebody said that,
who said that?
Wasn't there some guy that
was saying that for while?
- Well, not everybody,
people are weak.
So they, you know,
like I said earlier,
they'd rather be
safe than to be free.
But for the most people,
the people that I would
like listen to me.
- What about the general idea
that on this side of things,
again, you wrote the book, it
was called, "The New Right".
I'm on the back of the book,
called you the Willy
Wonka of politics.
One of your greatest
accolades, I think.
- I love that!
Can I tell you one thing
in all seriousness?
Harvey Pekar, the
late comic book writer
of "American Splendor" fame,
he wrote a book about me
called "Ego and Hubris"
that came out in 2006.
It goes for $300 on eBay now.
- I've seen the
pictures on eBay.
- When I watch "Charlie
and the Chocolate Factory",
the Johnny Depp version,
which is superior,
I do cry a little bit
and I'm not kidding,
because Harvey gave
me that golden ticket.
Harvey's the one who saw
something special in me,
who saw someone unique and
put his reputation on the line
and said, I'm going to write
a book about this freak
and that was such a major step
in me becoming independent.
So if you're not, if you
are that special person
and people don't like special,
they want everything
to be the same.
They want to watch
"Big Bang Theory".
They want to watch,
you know, Chris Cuomo.
When you're an outlier,
people aren't trained
on how to handle you.
Some people be drawn to you.
A majority will
be put off by you.
But when you meet
your maker, I promise,
you are going to be
able to, like you said,
hold your head up high
because you lived
according to your values.
- So Jordan been, since I
just mentioned Jordan that,
what you just said right there,
did you happen to see
the clip that went viral
of Jordan in the
last couple of weeks,
where he was on Tucker
Carlson's Fox Nation Show
and he's talking about telling
the truth for truth sake.
Did you happen to see
this by any chance?
- I have not.
- So we're going to lay
the clip in right here.
- You know, you, you, you
make your decisions in life
and I decided when I was
very young, in my mid 20s,
that I was going to
say what I believed
and see what happened.
I talked to you earlier in
the talk about adventure,
you know, about the
adventure of truth
and I don't think I'm happy
about what has happened
and I certainly have
dragged my family
through their fair
share of well, both hell
and also incomprehensible
opportunity.
It's expanded their
lives in both directions
to a tremendous degree,
but it's certainly
been an adventure.
It's not being dull.
And I don't believe that it,
I don't believe that
it was a mistake.
Whatever happens as a
consequence of telling the truth
is the best thing
that can happen.
It doesn't really matter how
it looks to you at the moment
or maybe even across the years,
'cause you have to,
it's a, it's a, it's a,
it's an article of faith
in some sense.
Do you believe that reality
is better constituted
as a consequence of
truth or falsity?
If you believe that
reality is best constituted
as a consequence of truth,
then you have a responsibility
to speak the truth
and you can't assess the
consequences and say,
well that was a mistake
because part of the decision
that reality is best
constituted as a consequence
of the truth is the
decision that no matter
what happens is the best
if it's a consequence
of telling the truth.
And so that's what I conclude.
It's like, this is what happened
because I said what I
had to say as clearly
as I could say it, and that's
as good as it could be.
Now, whether or not that's good,
well it's good compared to
all possible alternatives,
all possible realistic
alternatives.
That's an article of faith
as far as I'm concerned.
You know, our culture is
predicated on the idea
that truth in speech is
of divine significance.
It's the fundamental
presupposition of our culture.
Well,
if you believe that,
then you act it out
and you'd take the consequences.
You're going to take
the consequences
one way or another, you know?
So you want the
truth on your side
or do you want to hide
behind false hoods?
- Okay, so I think
you understand
why I wanted to play that clip
just as you were saying that.
- It's very Ayn Rand
in his messaging.
That's Jordan
Peterson at his best.
A lot of people who are fans
of mine are huge Jordan fans.
You can, I always knew why
but seeing him work his magic--
First of all, I'm just
delight in a personal level
that he's being, that he's
back from his health issues,
that he's being this cogent.
But yeah, Rand, Ayn
Rand had that point
about reality is true.
It is the standard
for what truth means
and that's the
definition of truth,
that which corresponds
to reality.
Ben Shapiro, you know obviously,
has a very famous quote
facts don't care
about your feelings.
Facts are what come first.
And if your worldview
is based on facts
as you understand them, we're
all limited in our knowledge,
we're gonna make mistakes
or we're gonna have
to kind of own
them and fix them,
but if you are trying
to act in a way
that corresponds to reality,
that corresponds to
what you regard as true,
even if you fail, at least
you will have the self-esteem
of knowing you fought
the good fight.
And truth is something
that every one of us
has to learn on our own.
Even if you tell me Dave,
that this is a great painter
for me to know that it's true,
I'll have to see it for
myself and do the mental work.
You can't have that telepathy,
but so much of corporate media
is the person in the screen
telling you this is
what the science is
and me or whoever,
going on social media
and repeating it verbatim.
That's not facts, that's not
truth, that's being a parrot.
- That's why I've been saying
we're in a war on truth.
That's what this thing
is a war on truth.
I wonder, do you see where,
where Rand and maybe Jordan
are divergent is
that at the end,
he's saying that that is the
ultimate expression of faith,
where I don't think
she would go that far.
And the reason I
brought all of this up
was because I also
wanted to link it
to that star that you've
got on your lapel.
- Well, in terms of Rand,
she was asked this
on Donahue in 1979.
I'm sure you're a
big fan of, and,
and her point was it's not,
the way he's using the
word faith, she goes,
he's like, you have
faith that you,
you know are accomplished or
whatever the question was,
she goes, that's not
faith, that's a conviction.
So it's not faith in
the religious sense of
received knowledge from,
you know, a higher power
or you know, I just have
this emotional experience
with the divine and therefore
everything else follows.
He means it in this--
I can't, I don't want
some words in his mouth.
The perception I
got is that he means
this is a conviction or
like an axiom basically--
- The leap to do that,
the leap of faith
to do that truth for truth sake.
- Yeah, so I mean,
he's, I'm kinda,
it takes a lot for
me to sit here.
and kinda not know what to
say, but when he nails it
like, there's no one better.
And I think it's very, very
sick that we have heard
from the left correctly,
for a very long time,
that these young men are being
raised without kind of models
for healthy behavior
and they result
in negative consequences.
Rape culture is one of the
things where this is like,
you know, no one's teaching
these men not to rape.
We need to teach
them how to rape
and Jordan comes along
and he tells young people,
your life can be better.
You can be a better
person tomorrow.
You may not be perfect,
but you could still be the
best version of yourself.
Here are some concrete,
actionable items
to improve your life and
as a consequence of that,
as a consequence of
teaching independence
and self-improvement, he's
a threat to the cathedral
and that's why he became
public enemy number one.
And you and I also have seen,
and everyone listening
to this has seen,
the demented glee in
his chemical dependency
and how people are happy
that something bad happened
to him where, if he has not,
I've never seen him really
wish harm on anyone.
- Ever, not once ever.
I can say that.
- I was on his show.
I'll tell you, I didn't know
when the episode's gonna drop,
and he goes, I'm not
going to do the voice.
He goes the way you talk
about academics, you know,
and just these really
nefarious terms,
where does that leave me?
And me being me I
said, Jordan, you know,
you'd be the last
one that we're going
to put up against the wall.
And after the interview--
- And I have no doubt
he had a huge laugh.
- I'm friends with his
daughter McKayla, I'm like,
I just said, your dad's
going to get shot.
But it, after that clip,
maybe we'll find
some space for him.
- All right, so
let's just link that
to that star that
you've got on your lapel
and then I want to do two
other things with you,
relative to what's going
on in the world right now,
in Israel and everything else.
- I, I think it is interesting.
I'm not an authority
on the Middle East,
but I think it is
interesting how so many times
when you have a group that's
just burning everything down,
that they are guarded
as the heroes,
simply because they're
weak and violent.
And we see this in
nation after nation
and it's a very dangerous
lesson to teach people.
I think Israel,
like any country,
has the right to
defend themselves.
And I also think if you are
defending yourself as a country,
if that's what they're doing,
this is a whole very,
very complicated issue,
who's you know, chicken and egg.
I do not believe defense
needs to be proportionate.
- It can't be.
- Right.
- I mean, you'd
actually be an idiot
If you were doing proportionate.
- If someone's breaking
into your house,
you don't just like
break into their house.
- Right, exactly, okay.
Let's do two more things because
I want to get some drinks with
the guy dressed like this.
So we're gonna just--
- Everyone does.
- I want to see you
drink through the mask.
It's gonna be red
wine through the mask.
Oh, here we go, oh,
this is how it ends.
You never disappoint,
Malice, you never disappoint!
This cartoon that I just
saw of you this morning,
you're doing a cartoon
with Tom Woods.
It's, it's, yeah...
Very failed
podcaster, Tom Woods.
It's a really wonderful,
not what do you call it,
the non, the politically
incorrect explanation
of communism?
I'm butchering is slightly.
- If they go to pigtvseries.
So there's a series of books
by Regnery, which I'm sure--
- Regnery, he's doing great
stuff, they published--
- And for decades they
have been doing good stuff.
So they had a series
of books called,
"The Politically
Incorrect Guides".
They have "Politically
Incorrect Guide to Feminism",
"Politically Incorrect
the Constitution"
to the United States.
So we adopted that and
it's a series of cartoons.
Me and Tom are animated.
We discuss issues like it's
politically incorrect guide
to communism, to the
Great Depression,
to Woodrow Wilson,
to American heroes.
We're putting them
out once a month.
And it's a great people--
The thing why I hate
government schools,
and this is something
that's not controversial,
people learn differently.
Some people learn by podcasts
through conversation,
some read, learn by books,
some learn by audio books,
some learn by documentaries.
None of these are
right or wrong.
It's just the human mind is
nuanced and perceives knowledge
and information differently.
So this is a fun way for
people to just sit down
and learn about these ethic
issues that we're not going
to learn the truth of dots
from the New York Times,
necessarily and if you
find it interesting,
you can go on and
explore from there.
So they're bite-sized pieces
that I'm really proud of.
- [Dave] What was
the website again?
-
TakeTVseries.com,
politicallycorrectguideTVseries.
- They're just great.
They're light and
fun and just great.
- And my goal, Tom, again, as
I mentioned early in the show,
he's a dad, Catholic,
he's got five daughters.
My goal is to get him in a dress
in as many episodes as possible
and I think I did
a good job of that.
- You haven't gotten
me in a dress yet.
- Well, not on camera.
- And it wasn't really--
It was getting you out of the
dress that was the problem.
(Dave laughs)
- Final thought
here, and I'm only,
I'm actually not mentioning
this for promotional purposes,
I'm mentioning this for purposes
that are completely in line
with everything
we've talked here.
You're crushing it on Locals.
You've built something
that is awesome and great.
and you've got your--
I always say there's
no trolls on Locals
and you always go, well wait,
wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
But we've built you
your own community,
where you're killing
it, basically.
- I am so grateful to you
and to my supporters.
It's Malice.locals.com,
as everyone knows,
because my goal wasn't like,
hey everybody I'm
such a bad-ass.
My goal is, there are
certain values that I hold,
come to the community.
You're going to find
people who think like you,
will have, we'll discuss,
people posts pictures
of their dog,
they post pictures
about their nephews,
they discuss politics.
But you know it's a
space where your neighbor
from high school,
like on Facebook,
isn't going to wish
death upon you.
And I think there's,
I was surprised,
and I think you were very
ahead of the curve on this.
There's a huge ethos on the
internet in the same way that
when you got a restaurant,
you tip the waitress.
If you see a creator
that is making it happen,
you toss them a few bucks
because they're the ones who
are kind of in the front lines
taking the bullets.
- Outsourcing of bravery.
- Oh yeah, I like that.
I'm going to pretend
I thought of that.
So the fact that I
have so many people
who are willing to toss
me five bucks a month
for nothing in return, I'm
still going to do the work
because they're like
you are taking the fight
that I as a business
owner, or a, you know,
a young professional
aren't a position to do,
that is very, very
humbling and flattering
and I could not
be more grateful.
And it also means I
don't have to be afraid
because if I had a
situation with Locals,
I'd get on the phone with you,
we would hash it out and
we'd come to some conclusion,
even if we have to
go our separate ways.
But I know I'm never
going to wake up
and have the community vanished
and have no explanation other
than some press release.
- Be very clear, Michael,
you're not getting
on the phone with me
'cause that's not what I do
but you'd get on the
phone with someone there
and guess what?
It's your community, you do
whatever the hell you want.
If you're breaking the
laws of the United States
you've got bigger
problems than Locals.
- You're taking my call, Rubin.
- I'll take your
call anyway, but not,
not about this sort of stuff.
You know, Malice, I didn't
know what I was walking into.
You said to me that, you
know, I should sit here first
before seeing you.
My guys got to see you.
I honestly thought you
were going to be dressed up
as Bea Arthur from
the "Golden Girls".
That was my, it was
just my gut feeling,
but you've you've
surprised me yet again.
And thus, you are the
Willy Wonka of politics.
- Well, thank you
Veruca, I appreciate it.
- Can you see my hand?
- I cannot.
Is it the finger?
- If you're looking
for more honest
and thoughtful conversations
about politics,
instead of nonstop yelling,
checkout our politics playlist.
And if you want to
watch full interviews
on a variety of topics, watch
our full episode playlists,
all right, over here
and to get notified
of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.